d'accord les gars nous y sommes nous sommes dans la
jungle nous sommes au fond de la jungle
je crois que je découvre de nouvelles terres de nouveaux
territoires vous pouvez voir cela aussi réel
que possible je n'ai pas eu d'eau pas de nourriture
j'ai attrapé du poisson avec mon nu
des mains que je ne reconnais même pas elles
ont trois têtes j'hallucine
ici j'ai eu aucun contact avec le
monde extérieur et c'est un oui on
garde juste la tête sur moi et on voit que comme
je le disais je découvre une nouvelle terre
bienvenue  à Jumanji tu as ruiné un tir fils
de [ __ ] tu as ruiné des
productions de trucs qui viennent d'être arrêtées ici sur un
plateau de Jemima pas à cause de la météo pas à
cause de l'environnement fou
qui tournait dans ce Jack Black avait besoin
de finir son Jack russe tu es bon je  Je suis
bon
ouais Jack a dit que je ne tirais pas de merde alors
j'ai fini mon [ __ ] de droit n'est-ce pas ce
droit jack il y a de bonnes choses en
fait Jack a dit que tu peux embrasser mon cul la
production peut t'attendre d'accord jack
va t'en grand gars quand est-elle  sortant des
jungles de Juma  nji sont incroyables mais il
faut faire attention car beaucoup de
moustiques et les Skeets sortent la
nuit
Keep Calm la nuit le whisky part à 9h00 les
enfants sortent la nuit
whoa les enfants
sortent bien il est 3h00 sur le plateau  nous venons de
terminer ici sur Jumanji ces fans
ici j'ai les plus grands fans du
monde ils ont littéralement
attendu ici quelque part
je ne sais pas 9 12 heures avec quelque chose
comme ça ici ils sont tous ici d'
accord d'accord bon de se rencontrer  bonne
nuit
toi